well the pet industry continues to grow
which is one of the big topics at this
year's super zoo convention at mandalay
bay in fact sales for pet products which
really doesn't surprise me all that much
10 billion dollars a year 100 billion
100 yes it's like 109. it's even more
than that see this is the woman with all
of the answers so excited to have you
here charlotte um because not only do
you know everything about um
the super zoo and pets but you also have
your radio show pet buzz i do i do
you're a woman it's so fun and it's so
nice to meet you because i
love kls 8 news now so let's talk about
what's new and hot okay yeah okay so
during covet at home testing just like
telemedicine kind of we got used to it
it's kind of part of our culture now and
they have the same thing for dogs and
it's for our dogs so this is a checkup
kit and it's great it's a very reliable
easy quick way to give like a wellness
check for your pet see how you can
exactly what you can do is the it's
urine testing okay and you can test for
ph blood protein and glucose the high
levels so this way you can always check
in it's going to avoid big vet bills and
it's going to avoid deterio pet health
deterioration okay so this these kits
are starting to be everywhere they're
great they're for dogs and cats there
are a variety of tasks
for a variety of conditions so a price
point is kind of all over the place
depending on you know it's a very
reliable price point but now they're
more accessible than ever it's a fairly
new product we love it okay awesome i
know you have a dog you have a big dog
yes do you brush your pet's teeth oh my
gosh i tried it's very difficult so hard
they just hassle exactly and you're
trying to hold the dog everything okay
so teverbrand's vitality has this great
alternative to brushing teeth it's brush
free it's twist and lick oral gel and
doesn't it look like a
container you turn the top twice okay
right for small dogs like wally four
times for big dogs like you and the gel
comes up at the top right the dog licks
it and what's that can you hold it and
what's great about it is
it is
featuring prolonged technology so what
that means is the dog licks it it gets
on the gums and the teeth and it
releases over a period of time you do it
once a week and what's nice about it is
it combats plaque and tartar
and then it freshens breath it whitens
teeth oh good whitens and brightens
teeth so it's great and so this is a
60-day supply
okay so i mean it's fantastic and you
have kissable breath i like that it
saves you a vet visit okay those dentals
are expensive i thought this was
phenomenal this is by loving pets right
here and they did you know dogs love pig
ears and bully sticks and antlers and we
kind of think they're natural so we love
giving them to them hard for their
tummies but hard for their tummy bad for
their teeth
i mean people don't think about it until
the teeth are all cracked and you're
spending lots of money at the veterinary
dentist and like just really overall
health problems so loving pets put
together better smarter treats that are
safer which i love and they look like
the real thing so i mean this is made
with pork but with actually 3d printing
and injection mold no it looks like the
real thing so these are the antlers look
at that check it out so they're made
with pork this is made with chicken and
also we also have the bully sticks right
here which is totally amazing and
they're actually made with bowling but
they're ground and they're healthier
smarter and you kind of still feel like
it's an alternative product sure and
it's an alternative product that works
because we love our pets so much but we
know they can be expensive oh my gosh my
guys cracked his teeth so this would be
a perfect test
and i'm sure the vet bill was outrageous
you might have even had to go to a
veterinary dentist
so i told you we have health we have
teeth we have chews now let's talk about
sustainability another big trend
that everyone is talking about it's not
just sustainable practices and
ingredients it's the whole corporate
policy so especially millennials and gen
z's are looking for healthier
for them and their dogs right but okay
on a corporate level too so this is
northwest naturals they do freeze dried
raw diets okay so these are their new
treat toppers their pork their chicken
and their beef okay they come in two
sizes so we have this big size right
here and we have
and they also have toppers but let me
tell you this company runs on solar
power they actually can source and trace
all of their products and they actually
everything they hardly have any
transportation to bring in stuff they
actually the bags and a lot of their
other stuff are made locally oh i love
it and the people are happy there and
they also so these are these hearts are
great and actually they're sliced up as
you can see right here because you can't
have like so these are great treats
they're and they're natural
when he's not sleeping exactly and then
you also have these great toppers you
have these three new flavors of toppers
you have beef liver with turmeric so
once again sustainable product that you
can source and treat something healthy
for them to put on their food there's a
little extra so turmeric is good for the
heart it's good for anti-inflammatory
properties okay then you have chicken
with green lip mussels so if you have an
older dog it's great for arthritis you
can call this one thank you i'm awesome
all right charlotte
last one is salmon with shiitake
mushrooms it's great for cognitive it's
great for the immune okay so yeah i mean
this is cool so sustainable all the way
100
and even
a half a megawatt solar factory see all
of the above we've got so much and we're
going to see you again here with some of
your products in a little bit so i'm
sorry we're out of time i gotta send it
back over to the other team in the other
studio but for now i'm charlotte thank
you
we've got more yay
all right guys thank you very much